- I don't think it's gonna be close to
the Mexican food whatsoever.
- Yeah, it doesn't look
like a taco whatsoever.
- To me it does.
- Looks like a salad.
- A taco isn't usually in
a flour tortilla, I mean--
- [Both] It comes in corn.
(girl laughs)
- I mean, looks like your basic burrito.
Beans, rice, chicken, guacamole.
- Why is the rice white?
- I can totally eat some of these.
- I don't know if this is
mayonnaise or sour cream, but--
- Yeah, I can't even tell,
it tastes like mayonnaise.
- Why are you making our
food, you know, into this?
- The Fritos, those do give them
a little different kind of taste.
- The cheese looks like the fake cheese.
- I don't know how people think
this is good, 'cause it's not.